good one more one more one more one more
still rolling ready
25 million per episode and over 2
496 shots with visual effects in the
series
how did wandavision do it the series
shows an array of genres from varied
decades to drama to total slapstick
comedy
so what did that mean behind the scenes
what were the secrets behind the magic
we'll be covering how the production
brought magic to the screen and what it
was really like for the performers
experiencing it
it's been really fun and different
however if you haven't watched the whole
series yet approach with caution
yes yes avengers end game had 2496 shots
with visual effects
and paul bettany aka vision has
confirmed that wandavision had even more
how is this even possible considering
how extensive the effects are for the
action-packed film
well the movie runs just over three
hours whereas the total running time of
all the one division episodes is a bit
over five and a half hours
not to mention multiple decades and this
fantastic transformation from a
grayscale world to color
at the end of the day a greater variety
and amount of vfx were needed to suit
the vision of the show
we should also mention that there were a
whopping 10 different effects companies
that contributed to one division
five and a half hours of content 10 vfx
companies and about 225 million dollars
spent on the entire series
yeah we can see how over 2500 vfx shots
make sense
i'll give you the role you chose as the
series continued we got to see more and
more of the marvel magic that we're used
to
and they didn't shy away from it when
wanda was in the town square surrounded
by the town's people of westview
watching this scene without all the
effects and wanda's red power blasting
through the hex is definitely different
but the sheer scale of it all is still
really impressive then of course we all
got to revel in the power of the scarlet
witch
naturally they couldn't really have
glowing red surrounding her entirely but
this green screen did the trick
olson's delicate and powerful hand
motions really do their job in making
this magic look real
add the glowing eyes and she is set
olson is no stranger to wire work
and thank goodness because she had
plenty of it in one division
she looks so calm cool and collected as
she descends down into the square here
i don't understand this power and how
about those epic battle scenes
olson said that this may actually be the
first time marvel had a full battle
sequence taking place entirely in the
air
take note of how many wires there are
all over these shots
the rigging is definitely no small task
thank goodness cgi is able to edit out
all the tricks of the trade used to make
the magic
though not everything needed a highly
technical vfx
adding some of this magic was as simple
as well cue the giant fans for agatha
it may have been her first time in the
mcu and defying gravity
but she looks like she's totally in her
element here as we can see
she wasn't holding back one bit and
seemed to really revel in the magic of
it all
how about these tense moments where the
actors appeared to simply be levitating
without all the wild movement and
soaring through the air
well as we can see here olsen was
essentially placed in a concoction of
wires to hold her up and floating in
agatha's chamber
it doesn't look too comfortable but the
final result well
it speaks for itself let's let agnes
give it a try
for a human playing a synthesiod betany
does an incredible job his vision
however credit has to be given to the
vfx team who did an incredible job at
using cgi for his face as well
yes he spends hours in the makeup chair
and gets a whole lot of prosthetics done
but to really bring the vision of vision
to life a team effort is needed
the acting emotion and heart that's all
betany
but his face is often cgi'd and
augmented with effects
his ears are really the main part cgi'd
out of the shot as we can see here
notice how detailed each layer that is
added is
each line on his head every ridge and
texture is added to really perfect the
look
let's also take a minute to acknowledge
how flawlessly he moves when he's flying
have you ever seen a more graceful sweep
and then of course
we all got to experience double vision
not too shabby
i wish to understand it tiana paris
actually had
no idea that she was auditioning to play
monica rambo and when she found out
well let's just say she was thrilled so
thrilled she even nearly tested her
superpowers on the spot
practically tried to jump off a set of
stairs because i thought i could fly i
was so excited
luckily she waited until she was on set
to try to find gravity
though flying isn't nearly as impressive
as what her character
actually went through remember when
wanda blasted her out of the hex
well fortunately paris didn't have to
bear the brunt of wanda's upset
instead it was a three-dimensional
figure based on pairs that was computer
generated and then added to the shots
and after vfx
though the intense rejection wasn't
quite enough to keep her out of the hex
and mesmerized us with the incredible
transition through static
and memory what were those digital
graphics inspired by exactly anyway
not to worry we'll be getting to that
soon
the hex is probably one of the most
powerful forces we've ever seen at play
in the mcu
we were majorly impressed by the fact
that the team managed to augment the
invisible barriers so intricately
this of course took loads of cgi the
main idea behind the visuals of the hex
was fairly obvious for the team
television what else could suit the show
better
the waves and graphics that we see used
here reflect what magnetization looked
like across the screen
what pixilation looked like when super
zoomed in to old-fashioned tvs
as well as the thin lines often seen on
those old tvs
it was all a reflection of the evolution
of television technology
everything might look fake in the tv but
everything in there is real
turning the sword base into a circus
well
let's just call it a very apt metaphor
check out what this setting looked like
before and after the cgi
accomplishing this transformation
actually wasn't too difficult according
to the vfx specialists
it was as simple as filming both
settings and then using cgi to augment
each one
one of the best complements a vfx or cgi
person can receive is that people had no
idea that some of what's seen on screen
is
actually created by computers one of the
more subtle and surprising cgi touches
was the stage found in the town square
at first glance we thought this
gazebo-like building was the same one
used by wanda and vision when they
perform in the talent show
but seeing the slightly different
looking structure in this later episode
we realize it's not any type of building
at all but a blue screen
this is one of those instances where we
really had to see it to believe it
a very small detail but it proves to us
just how much magic there is
who knew this seemingly simple frame
would be one of the over 2500 with added
effects
no abracadabra it wasn't all too serious
on set though
the cast definitely had their fair share
of fun especially with
so many key players like tiana paris
deborah joe rupp and catherine hahn
joining the mcu for the very first time
we just love how enthusiastic rep was
about having her body scan done for cgi
honestly we'd probably be just as
excited
han was enjoying herself so much that
she even made some entrances
way earlier than she needed to it's okay
though
we wanted all the agatha we could get
but it wasn't
just the newbies who had a wild time
olson herself started to push it in the
episode that she goes through an
entire pregnancy in a day and went a bit
too over the top
granted wanda's hormones were going wild
at that point
or maybe it had something to do with
that wig
[Laughter]
all that money skill time and effort
definitely worth it
seeing how intricate all the behind the
scenes action is makes us even more
impressed seeing the final product
from the old-fashioned to the highest
tech every visual absolutely hits the
mark
which effects did you find most
[Music]
impressive